a client wishes to free another man of
his earthly possessions
more specifically we need you to swipe
carry uradine's guitar the job is simple
the reward high
more intel attached i'll be waiting
can't have bad luck all the time save
you some time
it's none of these how do you know
because say what you will about
carrie but he knew guitars and these are
all hot
trash
hmm huh i'll never forget this
line was longer than from here to
plymouth rock after party lasted two
nights straight
and ended in the drunk tank
huh interesting [ __ ] carrie's an old
geezer now
when was this still taken not long ago
look
the date and the guitar we came for
look here the safer numeric keys
the date on that still with the guitar
we got buddy
well since he was carrying stan then
yeah damn sure of it
[Music]
of course the chicks made up for that
best [ __ ] i ever ate
[Music]
be careful
concealment before corporation forces is
a crime
[Music]
[Music]
keep up the pressure touch your weapon
heads are the corporation forces
what a
do
mess
[Music]
[Music]
see
i can truly count on you the guitar is
in the right hands
securely now close